Solo han pasado dos días desde las
elecciones en la capital aturca aquí el
51% de los votantes eligieron al
candidato de la oposición pero aún así
el presidente conserva su puesto
hoy Estamos contentos ganó la voluntad
popular es la voluntad del pueblo
yo digo que Turquía está tomando un
rumbo equivocado y seguirá por el camino
equivocado Y créanme que todos nos vamos
a dar cuenta Estoy jubilado lo más
importante para nosotros es que aumenten
las pensiones y los salarios la economía
es el mayor reto erdogan cree firmemente
que los tipos de interés generan
inflación aunque los economistas dicen
justo lo contrario Pero según este
antiguo diputado de la Cape el nuevo
gabinete podría estar abierto a nuevas
perspectivas
el presidente y su nuevo gabinete
considerarán quizá nuevos movimientos
por lo que he oído habrá una muy buena
gobernanza económica en Turquía que
dejará satisfecho a la nación turca como
a los inversores Internacionales y a los
países extranjeros
la ira del presidente se dirige a menudo
contra Europa y occidente en general sin
embargo la Unión Europea es el mayor
socio comercial de Turquía
creo que Turquía también empezará a
recalibrar sus relaciones con occidente
creo que el hecho de que la mayoría de
los líderes europeos como el presidente
enviarán mensajes al presidente erdoan
es un indicio importante de que
occidente está dispuesto a seguir
colaborando con Turquía
ahora todas las miradas están puestas de
la elección del gabinete en particular
en el próximo ministro de economía
alguien que tendrá la difícil tarea de
volver a llenar las arcas turcas frenar
la inflación y recuperar la confianza de
los inversores internacionales